retrouvailles devant le palais de
justice les anciens salariés de logo ne
se sont pas réunis depuis plusieurs mois
ce matin les assiste à une audience
devant le conseil des prud'hommes le
dossier que leur avocat s'apprête à
plaider a été fait il reproche à
l'ancien pdg de la lunetterie une
mauvaise gestion mais aussi une
situation de cours emploi par deux
sociétés
on attend la reconnaissance de par le
conseil des prud'hommes qui juge que la
cité une veste in qui est détenue par
monsieur vives qui est aussi le
dirigeant de la société logo donc que
cette société soit déclaré qu employeur
et ça nous permettra de démontrer que en
réalité monsieur vives par
l'intermédiaire d'une veste in et gérer
les salariés logo et dans la mesure où
il n'ont pas été licenciés par investing
mais par logo vient demander des
dommages et intérêts
la lunetterie logo à mort est évident
depuis sa liquidation judiciaire en
novembre 2016 depuis les salariés ont
mené plusieurs actions en justice
ils ont d'abord attaqué lvmh le
principal client de l'entreprise pour
avoir instauré une situation de
dépendance économique
cette action s'est terminée avec un
accord financier cette fois aux
prud'hommes
67 des 170 anciens salariés attendent
des dommages et intérêts et surtout la
reconnaissance d'une responsabilité
fleuve ancien pdg monsieur vives soient
considérés comme responsables de ce qui
est arrivé chez logo et que voilà
mais c'est possible doivent payer un peu
ce qui arrive on passe quand tous les
jours devant lusignan qu'orly cible
qu'on avait dessiné tout des fois il ya
encore de la lumière donc non non c'est
assez dur quand même à vivre même si
maintenant oui où
certains arrivent à faire l'impasse
parce que ils ont retrouvé du travail
certains sont classés d'autres pas mais
si si selon c'est quand même long mais
c'est le prix à payer pour se battre et
puis avoir gain de cause
après deux heures d'audience la sphère a
été placé en délibéré jusqu'au 18 mai
mais les anciens salariés en sont
persuadés dans tous les cas il y aura
appel de la décision du conseil